[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter
les faits ni sur la liste des morts dit
sur la bbc une solide et hopitalisé il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
les cas de kobe 19 toujours en hausse en
france plus de deux cents dix neuf mille
contamination enregistrés en 24 heures
aujourd'hui cela fait plusieurs jours
que les chiffres battent des records
résultats al'approche de la rentrée
scolaire le port du masque en extérieur
est étendue aux enfants dès 6 ans la
mesure prend effet lundi
[Musique]
la france qui prend la présidence de
l'union européenne pour six mois 2022
doit être l'année d'un tournant européen
c'est ce qu'avait lancé emmanuel macron
lors de ses voeux du nouvel an il s'agit
selon le président de rendre une europe
puissante dans le monde est pleinement
souveraine les précisions dans ce
journal
[Musique]
enfin nous irons en tunisie pour parler
du lancement de la consultation
populaire une plateforme électronique
devant accueillir les souhaits des
tunisiens quant aux réformes souhaitées
par un cahier sayyed le président
tunisien qui s'est arrogé les pleins
pouvoirs depuis fin juillet
[Musique]
il est 20 heures merci à vous si vous
nous rejoignez pour ce journal ravi de
vous retrouver sur rt france au premier
jour de cette nouvelle année 2022
une nouvelle année qui commence fort
avec des combis de contamination
toujours en hausse de 132 milles
contamination en 24 heures invariants
omicron qui poursuit sa propagation
conséquence de nouvelles mesures sont
mises en place dès lundi le port du
masque sera obligatoire pour les enfants
n'ont plus dé 11 ans mais six ans cela
concerne les transports collectifs ou
encore les déplacements dans certains
endroits comme les restaurants
concernant la pression dans les hôpitaux
d'après santé publique france elle reste
forte avec un nombre d'hospitalisations
importante pour cause de covin mais tout
de même moins soutenu que depuis le
début de la semaine
une épidémie toujours là mais pour notre
éditorialiste michel fille ce n'est pas
la principale préoccupation des français
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat notamment
est pour lui une difficulté bien plus
palpable parmi la population écoute et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ils ont deux
grosses inquiétudes dont celle dont on
parle beaucoup évidemment lakovic 19 mai
l'inquiétude pour leur pouvoir d'achat
pour leur pouvoir de vivre décemment
tout simplement on
on peut rappeler l'envolée des prix de
l'énergie un ces derniers mois l'envolée
des prix des produits alimentaires des
assurances des taxes des impôts toute
sorte un les factures s'alourdisse au
fil des semaines et au fil des mois ça
c'est le concret 1 c'est effectivement
quelque chose d'ailleurs qui a échappé
semble-t-il au président implique qu'il
n'a pas du tout abordé cette question du
pouvoir économique des français et des
plus démunis en particulier faut savoir
que quand on gagne 500 euros par mois ce
qui est le cas pour une personne au rsa
une personne d'une personne seule il
reste pas beaucoup quand on a fait le
tour évidemment des des rayons des
rayons alimentaires voilà donc beaucoup
de français n'arrivent plus à joindre
les deux bouts et pour beaucoup les fins
de mois commencé le 10 voire avant
couvre-feu pour trois semaines à la
réunion il est entré en vigueur ce
samedi les sorties sauf motif impérieux
sont interdites entre 21h et 5h du matin
sur place le taux d'incidence de
l'épidémie n'a jamais été aussi élevé
depuis le début de la crise 645 cas pour
100000 habitants à ce propos écoutez
l'analyse de patrick l'allemand et les
colonels et médecin chef du sdiss 974
familiaux de couvre-feu à se réparer le
prêter la réunion était attendu à raison
comme vous l'avez signalé à une
augmentation de la pression hospitalière
dans le département de la réunion
amplement nous disposons de 89 lits de
réanimation
84 lits sont occupés et parmi ses 95
lead presque la moitié sont liées à des
patients qu'au bilan lors de la dernière
vague la réunion a bénéficié du soutien
des personnels de santé de métropole
mais comme vous l'avez dit et toute la
métropole est impacté par le cos vide et
donc la réunion doit en mettre en place
de mesures pour essayer de se suffire à
elle même et si elle ne se suffit pas
elle même il faudra refaire ce qui s'est
passé au moins une fois l'an dernier un
bac c'est à dire organiser des avions
sanitaires transporter plusieurs
personnes en réanimation de saint denis
de la réunion a en métropole en
martinique les manifestations se
poursuivent en particulier celles des
professionnels de santé qui me sont
toujours pas vaccinées ils avaient
jusqu'à hier pour se conformer aux
directives du gouvernement désormais ils
s'exposent à des sanctions les
précisions avec yves ollivier mais
ils ont résisté jusqu'au bout syndicats
soignants et pompiers martiniquais ont
défilé ce mercredi à fort de france ils
étaient environ 300 à marcher en
direction de la préfecture après l'échec
des pourparlers avec les services de
l'état sur la question de l'obligation
vaccinale pour jouer l'apaisement face à
une grogne de plus en plus dur
le premier ministre jean castex avait
annoncé fin novembre la création d'une
instance de dialogue elle devait
accompagner individuellement chaque
personnel de santé vers le vaccin mais
c'est justement la mainmise de
l'exécutif sur ce processus cas dénoncés
l'intersyndicale elle appelle également
à ne pas suspendre les réfractaires à la
vaccination
les accords
et comme nous puissions
les travaux de
l'atelier de manière correcte comme on
dit on dit que ce n'est pas à
l'administration de mener les barreaux
pour nous mais c'est bien à nous
l'intersyndicale qui avery ici et son
mouvement qui devrions prendre les rênes
des choses et qu'on nous fasse pas faire
ce qu'on ne veut pas faire près de 800
personnes dont la moitié sont des
personnels du chu de martinique se sont
inscrits à ce système d'entretiens
personnalisés via la plateforme
téléphonique mis en place par la crs à
la conférence régionale de la santé et
de l'autonomie de l'île celle ci est
donc chargé de jouer les intermédiaires
avec l' agence régionale de santé et son
responsable oeuvre activement à la
réussite de cette initiative qui
éviterait de voir les services de
l'hôpital public déjà très impactées par
le cos vide sombrer dans une crise
beaucoup plus grave à l'issue de cet
entretien ils auront huit jours pour
prendre leur décision
soit ils
se vaccine et l'a peut-être on pourra
les orienter sur le type de vaccin qui
consiste qui constitue le moins de
crânes de leurs parts
soit il refuse définitivement ou pour le
moment en tout cas de se faire vacciner
auquel cas la mesure
de suspension va s'appliquer alors que
le simple fait qu'ils se soient inscrits
sur la plateforme de la crs à suspens
toutes les sanctions qui auraient pu
être prises à leur égard il faudra
attendre quelques jours pour savoir si
les arguments de la crs à auront été
assez fort pour convaincre les premiers
inscrits à ces entretiens
le forfait patients urgence entre en
vigueur ce 1er janvier votée par
l'assemblée nationale en octobre 2020 il
remplace l'actuel ticket modérateur
prise en charge à 80 % par
l'assurance-maladie concrètement après
un passage aux urgences sens
hospitalisation il faudra régler sur
place une somme d'un peu moins de 20
euros les précisions avec nadège
abderrazak
nous sommes devant l'hôpital georges
pompidou fut ici comme ailleurs à partir
de ce 1er janvier vous passerez à la
caisse après tout passage aux urgences
qui ne nécessite pas d'hospitalisation à
vous devrez immédiatement réglé en
forfait de 19 euros fait 61 centimes non
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
jusqu'à présent il fallait attendre
plusieurs semaines pourra recevoir une
facture à son domicile qui variait selon
les actes pratiqués à l'hôpital
l'assurance-maladie s'acquittait de 80%
des frais avec un reste à charge de 20%
pour le patient et sa complémentaire de
santé qui assumait totalement ou
partiellement le remboursement de ces
frais le but est d'homogénéiser la
participation hospitalière des patients
pour les soins non hospitalisés
actuellement la complexité de la
facturation des urgences d'aujourd'hui
l'illusion de la gratuité pour les
patients et les établissements il ya
toujours eu un reste à charge mais
facturé bien après puis ce reste à
charge est difficile à lire aujourd'hui
ce nouveau forfait patients urgences
devraient être prises en charge par
l'aide médicale d'état ou les
complémentaires santé qui sont
obligatoires pour la majorité des
salariés et dont bénéficient
95% des français pour les 5 autres pour
cent de la population qui sont
généralement des demandeurs d'emploi ou
des retraités c'est un changement
notable prendre en compte a fortiori
pour les seconds dont l'âge accroît
mécaniquement le recours à l'offre de
soins sur la toile de nombreuses voix
dénoncent une discrimination envers les
plus précaires et un renforcement des
inégalités le coup des 20 euros par
passage aux urgences c'est vraiment un
truc de parisiens débiles qui n'a aucune
idée de ce qu'est un désert médical
et/ou qui n'a jamais eu d'enfant du coup
faudra aller aux urgences que si tu es
sûr d'être en phase terminale à partir
du 1er janvier le personnel soignant
déjà débordé une des urgences déjà
surchargés devra faire passer à la
caisse 19 euros que les patients et
patientes sont mutuels c'est à dire les
plus précaires payeront plein forfait à
ajouter dans le palmarès des mesures
indigne de ce quinquennat le service des
urgences qui devient payant pour les
personnes n'ayant pas de mutuelle ces
criminels 18 euros c'est plus d'une
semaine de courses alimentaires pour
certaines personnes cette décision va
faire mourir des gens qui nous ont pas
aller se faire soigner un montant unique
de 19 euros 61 pour tous excepté pour
les femmes enceintes de plus de 5 mois
et les personnes atteintes par une
affection de longue durée pour elle le
forfait sera minorée à 8 euros 49 à
noter tout de même mais c'est vraiment
la moindre des choses que les enfants
victimes de sévices les victimes de
terrorisme et les malades du coït dans
le cadre de l'urgence sanitaire seront
pour leur part exemptées des frais reste
que ce dispositif pose aussi des
problèmes de logistique à certains
hôpitaux la nuit par exemple il n'ya pas
toujours de secrétaires médicaux il y à
des infirmiers et des aides soignants
qui sont avant tout là pour les soins et
dont ce n'est pas la mission première de
passer une carte bleue les hôpitaux ne
sont pas des supermarchés où il faut
passer à la caisse cette réforme découle
de travaux menés en 2019 à la demande du
premier ministre de l'époque edouard
philippe objectif de ce nouveau
fonctionnement à désengorger les
urgences et réduire les un pays on a des
difficultés pour réunir les informations
est facturé aux bons débiteur et ensuite
des difficultés pour récupérer quand on
a identifié le bon débiteur la somme 213
millions d'euros c'est le montants
facturés aux patients dans les hôpitaux
en france d'après une étude d'impact
seuls 33% sont recouvrées ce nouveau
dispositif pourrait permettre de
récupérer 35 millions d'euros au péril
du principe de la quasi gratuité des
soins sur le territoire français pour
les retraités et les demandeurs d'emploi
je vous le disais en titre après la
slovénie au tour de la france de
présider le conseil de l'union
européenne pour six mois les ambitions
sont fortes dans ce contexte de pandémie
2022 doit être l'année d'un tournant
européen c'est ce qu'avait lancé
emmanuel macron lors de ses voeux du
nouvel an la france qui va à disposer
d'un important pouvoir d' influence afin
de faire avancer certains sujets et de
trouver des compromis à 27 grégoire
douce et
impulser une ligne directrice pour
l'union européenne tel est le rôle
attribué à la france pour les six
prochains mois plusieurs axes
prioritaires ont été définis par le
président français souveraineté
européenne environnement ou encore les
questions sociales vous pouvez compter
sur mon engagement total pour faire de
ce moment qui ne survient qu'une fois
tous les 13 ans un temps de progrès pour
vous un temps de progrès pour la
maîtrise de nos frontières
notre défense la transition climatique
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la construction d'une alliance nouvelle
avec le continent africain le meilleur
encadrement des grandes plateformes de
l'internet et la culture en europe
principal allié de la france l'allemagne
dans une configuration politique
nouvelle après les saisons de règne
d'angela merkel est la figure
écologistes anna bareback intégrés au
gouvernement allemand de coalition en
tant que chef de la diplomatie voit d'un
bon oeil la présidence française nos
amis français peuvent compter sur notre
soutien du premier au dernier jour pour
poser les bons jalons au sein de l'union
européenne pour une reprise économique
durable dans la lutte contre la crise
climatique dans la numérisation et pour
une europe plus souveraine dans le monde
une chance importante que nous voulons
saisir ensemble pour renforcer l'europe
et la rendre à relever les défis de
demain
particularité de cette présidence elle
intervient en pleine campagne pour la
présidentielle française et connaîtrait
deux dirigeants différents dans le cas
où emmanuel macron ne serait pas réélu
peut-être que la politique de la france
changera à coup sûr la france restera la
france en tout cas je ferai tout pour et
je le ferai durant les prochains mois
jusqu'aux échéances
électorales qui sont les nôtres croyez
le bien fardeau ou atout pour le
locataire de l'elysée en vue d'une
réélection en avril difficile de le
prédire cette présidence française
pourrait en tout cas faire partie
intégrante du débat électoral
l'euro fête ses 20 ans le 1er janvier
2002 des millions d'européens changer
leur quotidien en abandonnant leurs
monnaies une victoire de l'europe
d'après le président jacques chirac à
l'époque l'euro qui a enthousiasmé
autant qu'il inquiète et 20 ans plus
tard où en est-on quelques repères
historiques en bref et en images
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela fait un an que le brésil a pris
effet une sortie du royaume-uni qui a
été délicate à mettre en place la
continue d'ailleurs de se faire
progressivement et aujourd'hui justement
de nouvelles procédures douanières vont
s'appliquer d'importants changements
également pour les britanniques
expatriés en europe et notamment en
france les précisions avec guimard aussi
si vous êtes ressortissant britannique
vous êtes probablement concernés par ce
qui va suivre en effet en ce jour de 1er
anniversaire du bric site de nouvelles
procédures entre temps vigueur et
notamment pour ceux d'entre vous qui
vivent et veulent continuer à vivre en
france et il aime pour qui compterait
s'y installer à l'avenir techniquement
depuis ce 1er janvier 2022 c'est cher
sujets de sa majesté doivent désormais
justifier d'un titre de séjour en tout
cas s'ils comptent rester plus de trois
mois sur le territoire français et oui
le royaume uni ayant quitté le il n'y a
plus de totale liberté de circulation
des personnes entre l'île et le
continent il y a bien eu en 2021 une
période transitoire au cours de laquelle
un passeport suffisait pour résider en
france mais ça désormais c'est terminé
alors comment ça va se passer d'abord
tous les ressortissants britanniques ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne à ceux
qui se sont installés en france avant le
31 décembre 2020 c'est-à-dire avant le
break sites sont éligibles à l'obtention
d'un titre portant la mention accord de
retrait cette autorisation de séjour est
valable cinq ou dix ans selon que le
demandeur a déjà résidé plus ou moins
longtemps en france et ceux qui en
bénéficient n'ont pas besoin
d'autorisation pour travailler ensuite
il y a les autres arrivées en france
après le break site donc à partir du 1er
janvier 2021 cela ils se verront eux
remettre un titre de séjour classique
dont la durée de validité et les
conditions d'attribution dépendent du
droit commun français en fait comme pour
n'importe quel autre ressortissants
extra-européens et ils doivent demander
l'autorisation d'occuper un emploi il y
a bien sûr d'état d'exception
particularités et conditions listée sur
le site du ministère de l'intérieur et
ces nouvelles mesures vont quand même
concerner beaucoup de monde selon nos
confrères des échos plus de 160 mille
demandes de titres de séjour ont été
enregistrées par les préfectures
françaises il n'y a par ailleurs pas que
la circulation des personnes entre lui
et le royaume uni qui se compliquent
depuis ce 1er janvier 2022 la
circulation des biens aussi à partir
d'aujourd'hui les importations
britanniques de marchandises en
provenance de l'union européenne devront
faire l'objet d'une déclaration
douanière systématique on attend de
nouveaux contrôles aux frontières et de
nouvelles règles sauf qu'apparemment les
entreprises elles sont loin d'être
prêtes alors même que d'autres
formalités doivent entrer en vigueur au
1er juillet de cette nouvelle année de
quoi mettre à rude épreuve encore un
temps le proverbial flegme de nos
voisins d'outre-manche
en tunisie la nouvelle année commence
avec le lancement d'une consultation
populaire une plateforme électronique
race à laquelle les tunisiens pourront
adresser leurs remarques demande sur des
sujets divers comme la santé l'éducation
ou encore l'économie cela doit servir de
base à la révision constitutionnelle
souhaitée par le président cahier ces
aides cela ne fait pas l'unanimité les
précisions de yamina benguigui
c'est un nouvelle en politique pour les
tunisiens qui sont invités aujourd'hui à
s'exprimer à travers une consultation
populaire
initiée par le président kaïs sayed une
participation par le biais d'une
plateforme électronique qui permettra
d'obtenir une forme de démocratie
directe selon le chef de l'état nous
ferons les réformes sur la base de la
volonté du peuple et non de ceux qui
l'ont escroquée six grandes thématiques
seront traités à travers ce nouvel outil
de consultation dont l'éducation le
système politique ou encore les affaires
économiques et financières
un comité devrait rassembler par la
suite toutes les propositions et en
tirer des suggestions de réforme en
prévision notamment de deux scrutins
prévue en 2022 le référendum
constitutionnel du 25 juillet et les
élections législatives du 17 décembre
une initiative qui ne ferait
qu'augmenter la confusion dans le pays
selon certains militants politiques je
trouve la création initiée depuis le 25
juillet encore plus confuse que qu'avant
le 25 juillet parce qu au moins avant le
25 juillet bien sûr avec tous les
problèmes économiques avec tous les
problèmes politiques avec tout ce qui se
passait et avait des institutions qui
fonctionnent et plus ou moins depuis le
25 juillet et a plus qu'une seule
institution et une seule personne qui
décide de l'avenir de ce pays des
nouvelles et nous l'avenir des nouvelles
générations et jusque là on n'a rien vu
de qu'il laisse de nous laisse croire
qu'il va y avoir des sparks vraiment un
des changements la consultation durera
du 1er janvier au 20 mars 2022 et se
fera de manière anonyme selon le
gouvernement les tunisiens devront
toutefois indiqué par sms leur numéro de
carte d'identité
une procédure qui pousse certains médias
locaux à s'interroger sur le caractère
confidentiel de ce projet autre aspect
controversé concernant cette initiative
les limites liées à la fracture
numérique sur le territoire en raison de
leurs conditions de vie ou de leur âge
certains tunisiens ne pourront pas
s'exprimer une situation qui pourrait
avoir une influence sur l'ampleur de la
participation
est toujours en tunisie le vice
président du parti d'opposition ennahda
nourredinne bhiri a été arrêté hier
figure forte de ce parti bête noire du
président il a été emmené par deux
agents en civil vers une destination
inconnue aucun détail n'a été donné sur
les motifs de cette arrestation mais le
ministère de l'intérieur a précisé dans
un communiqué de l'assignation à
résidence de plusieurs personnes le
parti ennahda qui a aussitôt dénoncé je
cite une liquidation des opposants hors
du cadre de la loi
nous jugeons que le ciblage de monsieur
berry est une tentative d'intimider les
autres personnalités une tentative de
couper la route devant la mobilisation
prévue le 14 janvier marquant
l'anniversaire de la révolution que le
mouvement ennahdha a appelé à célébrer
et appeler les gens à manifester dans
les rues
dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale en bref et en images
l'afrique du sud qui a fait ses adieux
au héros de la lutte contre l'apartheid
les obsèques de desmond toutou décidé
dès le 26 décembre dernier à se sont
déroulés dans la cathédrale anglicane de
cap dont il a été longtemps l'archevêque
cette cérémonie et marque la fin d'une
semaine d'hommages cette figure majeure
du pays
l'inde endeuillée par une bousculade
mortelle au moins douze personnes mortes
et une dizaine d'autres blessés cette
nuit au cours d'un mouvement de foule
dans le cachemire indien le drame s'est
produit dans l'un des sanctuaires inde
où les plus fréquentés du nord du pays
le premier ministre la reine drame audi
a rendu un hommage aux victimes
et puis en irak rassemblement pour
marquer le deuxième anniversaire de
l'assassinât par les états unis du
général iranien qasem soleimani ce
samedi ils étaient plusieurs milliers de
partisans deux factions armées
irakiennes à descendre dans les rues de
bagdad pour demander le retrait des
soldats américains du pays le 3 janvier
2020 véhicule dans lequel se trouvait
qasem soleimani avait été pulvérisé par
un drone sur ordre de donald trump
et pour terminer ce journal est commencé
cette année 2022 retour sur les faits
qui ont marqué 2021 à travers le monde
est là mais jets
aux états unis des partisans de donald
trump envahissent le capitole à
washington où siègent les parlementaires
faisant trembler la démocratie
américaine
ces violences inédites font six morts
mais c'est bel et bien joe biden élu à
la majorité qui est investie
officiellement 46e président des états
unis le 20 janvier chef de facto du
gouvernement hong sang-soo 6 75 ans est
renversé par un coup d'état militaire en
birmanie la prix nobel de la paix est
arrêtée tout comme le président l'armée
déclare l'état d'urgence pour une durée
d'un an
kaboul tombe aux mains des talibans au
pouvoir entre 1996 et 2001 ils entrent
sans combattre dans la capitale afghane
et chassent le gouvernement en place des
milliers d'afghans désespéré tentent de
fuir le pays après vingt ans de présence
militaire les derniers soldats
américains quittent définitivement
l'afghanistan le 30 août
le gouvernement australien met fin au
contrat du siècle avec le constructeur
français navale groupe canberra se
rapproche alors des états unis et du
royaume uni pour s'équiper de sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire
une décision qui provoque une crise
diplomatique
inédite la france s'estime trahie et
dénonce un coup dans le dos c'est une
énorme déception plusieurs milliers de
migrants se massent à la frontière
polonaise varsovie l'union européenne
accuse le président de la biélorussie de
faire venir des personnes du
moyen-orient en leur promettant une
entrée facile dans lieux pour lutter
contre cet afflux migratoire la pologne
déploie un important dispositif de
sécurité à sa frontière et projette la
construction d'un mur
après 16 ans de pouvoir ennuyée la
merkel choisi de ne pas se représenter
la chancelière allemande cette sa place
au social démocrate olaf scholz
vainqueur des élections fédérales
souvent perçue comme la femme la plus
puissante du monde en gueule à merkel
aura vu passer quatre présidents
français
la force française barkan rend le camp
de tombouctou à l'armée malienne c'est à
la fin de près de neuf ans de présence
ininterrompue dans cette ville du nord
du mali ce départ définitif s'inscrit
dans le processus de désengagement
militaire de paris au sahel sur fond de
contestation de la présence française
dans la région
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi prochain
point sur l'actualité dans une trentaine
de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
lily à ces dérives plus classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire ainsi internet on est moins
soudé jaune mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait la voir errer
sur dix 81 que sur des phénomènes qui
vont concerner la santé ou
l'alimentation et la crise du coc vide à
renforcer cette nouvelle porte d'entrée
en les dérives sectaires ou des gourous
vous plutôt parler de vaccination plutôt
parler d'alimentation plutôt parler de
guérison au lieu d'aller directement sur
un terrain qui sera un terrain religieux
ou mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti vaccin
contre le coc vides certains éléments
qui se rattachent à des mouvements à
tendance sectaire qui historiquement
sont opposés à toute vaccination
[Musique]
le doute plane encore sur la tenue de la
can 2022 au cameroun la caf réfléchirai
à annuler la compétition quelles sont
vos informations c'est clairement une
fake news aujourd'hui en afrique cette
campagne d appliquer vu comme un
sabotage pour cette can à 2022 les yeux
sont rivés sur le fameux stade de limbé
confronté à des retards de travaux et un
scandale financier présumé avec le
nouveau prélat la fécafoot nous savons
que les choses vont se passer pour
l'équipement s'est peint tous les pays
africains qui selon de désormais capable
d'organiser une canne avec quatre
équipes on ne peut pas priver l'africain
de leur compétition de phare
la cale à ce jour au cameroun ld plus qs
le 9 janvier
[Musique]
oh
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches je
vais vous faire part d'un secret le
royaume uni n'a pas disparu contre toute
attente